never close your lips to Those whom you
have already opened your heart to
a man is lucky if he is the first love
of a woman
a woman is lucky if she is the last love
of a man
listening to wise quotes is like living
The Human Experience
fill your wisdom with Charles Dickens
quotes we've collected for you in this
video
you were born to be alone
if you don't have the ability to yield
[Music]
procrastination is the thief of time
color it
[Music]
share money and secrets with your
friends
but never let yourself be excused
[Music]
ask no questions and you'll be told no
lies
a very little key will open a very heavy
door
some people are nobody's enemies but
their own
no varnish can hide the grain of the
wood
and that the more varnish you put on
the more the grain will Express itself
the pain of parting is nothing to the
joy of meeting again
[Music]
a day wasted on others is not wasted
onto oneself
[Music]
my advice is never do tomorrow
what you can do today
[Music]
take nothing on its looks
take everything on evidence
there's no better rule
there are books of which the backs and
covers are by far the best parts
[Music]
it's in vain to recall the past
unless it works some influence upon the
present
love those said to be afflicted with
blindness
is a Vigilant Watchman
[Music]
there is wisdom of the head
and there is wisdom of the heart
family not only needs to consist of
merely Those whom we share blood
but also for those whom we'd give blood
we forged the chains we wear in life
one word in Earnest is as good as a
speech
children from unsuccessful marriages are
always especially in a hurry to get
married
happiness is a gift
and the trick is not to expect it but to
Delight in it when it comes
[Music]
there is no worse deception in the world
then self-deception
no space of regret can make amends for
one's life's opportunity misused
no one who can read ever looks at a book
even unopened on a shelf like one who
cannot
[Music]
one should never be ashamed to cry
tears are the rain on the dust of Earth
people involved in charity are divided
into two categories
some do nothing
but make a big fuss
While others do a big deed
but without any noise
[Music]
a loving heart is worth more than all
the wisdom in the world
Trifles make the sum of life
all our lives we commit the most
cowardly acts with an eye on Those whom
we do not put a penny on
have a heart that never hardens and a
temper that never tires
and a touch that never hurts
women can always put things in the
fewest words
except when it's blowing up and then
they lengthen it out
[Music]
there is prodigious strength and sorrow
and despair
cheerfulness and contentment are great
beautifiers
and our famous preservers of good looks
[Music]
thinking about someone
we thus get the right to expect
something from this person
the occasion itself does not come to a
person but it is necessary to catch it
in a utilitarian age of all other times
it is a matter of grave importance that
fairy tales should be respected
[Music]
no one is useless in this world who
lightens the burdens of another
think now and then that there is a man
who would give his life
to keep a life you love beside you
moths and all sorts of ugly creatures
hover about a lighted candle
can the candle help it
[Music]
there can be no disparity in marriage
like unsuitability of mind and purpose